hey guys we want to talk to you about
something called original grain if
you're living under a rock you might not
know what it is but dude look how boss i
look why why do i look boss because of
the watch because of the sunglasses we
sold out of these sunglasses last i had
so if you want something go get it now
uh father's day is coming up i know
cause i'm a father also i'm a person
matt even knows he's not a father i have
a father you have a father i have a
father too because we're brothers this
is the boss one right here this is the
boss one that i like and you know your
boy's future's too bright so go get the
sunglasses too check out this ring yeah
they got a lot of stuff um look they've
been making watches original green's
been making watches from unique
materials for almost a decade every
watch they sell they plant a tree and
have planted over half a million trees
so do you want to look boss and also be
a good person yeah original grain is for
you
veteran and family-owned company started
by two brothers much like me and him but
probably more responsible and better
yeah in the pacific northwest over
twenty thousand five star reviews
so here's so many i know it's a lot
right
well we're gonna sell out of all our
inventory before father's day so make
sure you get them early at
originalgrain.com
lifeline for 30 off you're probably like
what
yes
30 off use cold lifeline at
originalgrain.com
lifeline to get 30 off site wide that's
the whole [ __ ] site yeah they also
make watches from other sustainable
materials materials like 100 recycled
ocean plastic uh reclaimed military ammo
and wood crates and reclaimed german
beer barrels
so no matter what
you resonate with there is a perfect
watch for you
that's code lifeline at
originalgrain.com
lifeline to get 30 percent off site wide
father's day is coming up go get it go
get your father's day gift taken care of
today
and be a good person and be boss and
have your future too bright be a good
son original grain or daughter
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed
[Music]
professional hello
[Music]
the cameras that are on me are working
best yeah okay good those are working
the worst because they're showing you
whoa
dude i burned you no good burned you
nope no i did burn you that's
technically a burn
so dude um we're we started it but uh
and this is lifeline you know and that's
great yeah man and it's episode seven
uh i think yeah seven right
anthony
you know what chris isn't here the
producer already [ __ ] seventh episode
and he's already [ __ ] not here he's
literally on vacation which is [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay that's shitty to do it
to uh to leave us hanging like that is
shitty yeah we don't like that and also
here's the deal he went on vacation and
uh
[Music]
last time was it last time he had no was
i think it was actually two shows ago
and we could talk about this now because
he's not here no it was definitely the
last it was okay cool every day's the
same day in a way so i never know oh so
um
so he
we ran out of videos
say it right say it right say it right
he ran out of videos he
he he collects the [ __ ] dozens of
videos no
we have we have hundreds of videos i'm
saying do we how many how many do you
think we have that we haven't used if
you had to get 100 we have hundreds i
know but i'm saying per week i guess
but we we got through them and it wasn't
like we ran through them it wasn't like
we burned through them at all it wasn't
like we were like fix your life next
yeah we weren't doing that yeah but he
but we ran through them yeah well we
didn't run through them but we got
through them right and then he was like
that was it that's it that's the videos
right so then he asked for some advice
which is very cool you get to understand
you know our producer chris and like his
struggles yeah he was talking about how
do i lose weight and stick to a plan
but we cut out the part where it was
like yeah we cut out the part where it
was like it made him look bad oh
about how running out of videos yes not
not okay yeah we want the raw [ __ ] here
at lifeline yeah you know and if you're
a fan of my podcast congratulations if
you're a fan of my [ __ ] you know i'm
wrong which is what you get the fact
that he cut it out now that's a no-no
right we don't like that but that's what
he did but that's a no-no but what i
want to be clear about is that he made a
mistake right because we were talking
about it earlier and we were like yeah
but before we started recording we were
like well what the [ __ ] remember we ran
out of videos right and then matt was
like yeah it was his fault yeah and i
was like
yeah well you know i mean it's not like
we ran through him but you know
i guess i just wanted to know how many
videos we had queued up today and he was
like it was his fault and he kept saying
it was his fault and i was like yeah you
think it is and he was like yes and i
was like maybe you're right and then i
said but what percentage
and you didn't answer this i said let's
wait you talk about on the podcast oh
right that's right yeah so i said i was
very ready to answer so what percentage
do you think it's his fault that we
didn't have enough videos for the last
episode one hundred percent come on you
think it's a hundred percent it's one
hundred percent so all right if we have
hundreds of videos
and he only put six up like what if we
did more okay why don't you just pad it
just pat it okay okay just pat it okay
then i have another question then okay
what if he had 20 videos queued up
and we burned through all of them and it
was under an hour whose fault is that
whose fault is it i mean i would say
that's nobody's fault that would be our
fault because we're not spending enough
time okay so so it can't be a hundred
percent his fault then if six i think it
was actually seven or eight videos
what if he'd what if he'd put two videos
then then his fault would have been then
it would 100
there you go that's i'm saying
is sliding then it's a sliding scale but
if it's if it's too little it's always
here so you think under 10 is 100 his
fault
yes eight is his fault a hundred percent
eight is a yeah okay exactly ten is the
right
ten would be maybe i'd be like okay it
starts to be not his fault
nine is like you really feel getting
nine is like maybe it's nine to be
perfectly honest but it's it's his fault
last episode his fault and we deeply
apologize is the thing but most of the
thing is we deeply apologize because
he's not on camera so we apologize on
his behalf right right but the truth is
it got cut in a way that that didn't
even
seem like he was seeking advice
he wanted to make sure oh right okay so
right now we got it okay so that's why
all right so that's why people didn't
understand yeah but we are exposing him
so basically he's exposed we're exposing
chris the producer and he's not here
right he's not even he could say and
we've talked about this for four minutes
and he's not going to cut it out because
there's no four minutes and we're going
to do just enough time right right to
where he can't cut it out because i know
the podcast would be too short he better
not he better not try i love figuring
stuff out like that okay if i had that
conversation with dad it would have been
so much more annoying what would have
been an hour it would have been the
whole year right we got it to zero
videos yes yes and we would have still
had videos for next time and that would
have been dad's fault
yeah that's true dude you know that's
like the [ __ ] how many me stripping
stripping
stripping the sandstorm that would be so
bad dude no dude that's like the number
one strip no you know what's the number
one strip super song
i wanna [ __ ] you like an anime
[Music]
song
i mean i had no [ __ ] idea what that
was and also what part of said song
because that doesn't sound like anybody
well they all kind of sound the same but
this one goes
i heard
[Music]
so rude how close your hand is to my
face
also were you saying like don't
interrupt me is that what that was
yeah well yeah here it comes so
[ __ ] rude dude if i just close your
mouth like this and tan it no or or
you're like a lollipop
mister take me with you yeah i know well
now we got to explain it okay so go
ahead that's the great thing to explain
mr takemay was a guy a japanese man who
taught spanish very funny in high school
in high school now we're not saying oh
look all walks of life all races can
teach whatever the [ __ ] they want equal
opportunity we're all about inclusion
but look dude
mr takemay was a japanese guy
see it's good to bring it up dude he's a
japanese guy i probably talked about
this all my pockets at some point but
just the this japanese guy who [ __ ]
uh
he taught in japanese thick accents
yeah he would say uh he would yeah i
mean he would say welcome
i mean like it was a tradition like a
japanese and you would be like
yeah and we were like it was very and i
remember was so confusing and i remember
one time he was like these kid the bad
kids came in class and they smelled of
like drugs and [ __ ] and alcohol and he
was going ah
[Music]
and i was like what and he said
and i was like what are you saying and
he said smoking oh
smoking
i had him but he would go
what was the thing yeah
yeah when you were talking no you would
go
look at his watch or whatever
you know like in between on a
walkie-talkie it'll go
[Music]
why would he go
because he was a human walkie-talkie
okay human walking talk that's it mr
tech made the human walkie-talkie that
sounds like a [ __ ] uh movie that
what's his name who did the isle of dogs
would do
oh wes anderson yeah west anderson would
do that uh uh mr take amazing isle of
dogs yeah mr take a may
the what is it the human walkie talkie
would be made by the guy who did the
[ __ ] stop saying the guy just said
wes anderson i just said wesley i forget
what his [ __ ] name is
wes anderson's name dude you don't know
anybody's name no that's not true mr
teckamay
the human walkie-talkie mr tecamay i in
my when i had him i made him i didn't
make him but he was one of those
teachers who was who were cool he was a
cool guy actually and he let us pick
it wasn't like i had to be mateo oh okay
i could i was crystal ball yeah yeah i
was zoro
okay wow and he thought it was funny and
every time i would raise my hand and he
would he would call on me and he'd go
oh yeah well you're really bringing me
back with how he used to talk he was
doing it you're right dude
yeah just so like and he would wear
hawaiian shirts yeah wow he was like a
very multicultural individual he was
he's probably dead now huh oh so
depressing well he's probably even he
was old then he couldn't maybe he's 90.
he's probably dead yeah wow okay [ __ ]
bummer r.i.p dude you ruled yeah you're
listening to us up there in heaven if
you're or down there in hell
he might be in hell you know what he
might be in hell for what he showed us
[ __ ] you know how like sometimes the
teacher would just be like [ __ ] i
don't i just wanna yeah like show you
guys a movie yeah you know yeah like i
gave up today yeah he showed us half
baked hopefully he's dead so now he's
not exposed and so uh
you get canceled for that [ __ ] out of
high school half baked dude
[ __ ] man well yeah i'm [ __ ] exhausted
and i'll tell you why dude because i was
in uh austin texas and then dallas texas
and then i flew home got here took a
ride to my house got dressed took a
shower that's why i look real nice and
then came here all the way [ __ ]
downtown doing lifeline and now i have a
spot at the laugh factory later i rock
it's fine i'm tired but i rock right
so this is the kind of [ __ ] i do to
bring you guys what you want that's true
that's too many things though
that's too many things
then i sleep
yeah and then you sleep for [ __ ] ever
you wake up at three and i'm trying to
text you all [ __ ] morning
i will dude how do you feel about the
fact that we're both wearing blue are
you as upset as i am no i like it oh
okay i like it i think it's good because
we haven't done it until the seventh
episode and we did it we did all
mismatch and we didn't really the first
episode we were like what are you
wearing the second ever episode i think
we did it and then after that we just
mismatched and we didn't even mean to
and now he finally matches episode seven
it's the matching episode and that's
good dude it took us seven episodes to
do that part's true what do you think
about wanna do this
it's unfortunate on the audio you can't
see what i'm doing you're just nodding
your head but i'm doing it slow and i'm
closing my eyes what do you think about
this it looks like you're finally
getting the blow job you wanted
like out of all the forever i just think
sometimes i stumble upon things and i
think that's how i'm going to do that
for the rest of my life cool so now when
someone's talking and i'm agreeing for
the rest of my life i'm just going to do
this
looks like you're [ __ ] falling asleep
over and over again
like constantly waking up like yeah yeah
like this
but i'm not because my eyes are closed
so i'm not doing the eye roll thing okay
well you said i was doing it like i was
falling still not right well whatever
man my advice to you is don't do that
because people are going to think you're
the biggest [ __ ] of all time
so that's my advice to you on lifeline
okay all right thanks
so yeah dude rip roaring this is my
[ __ ] fourth coffee of the day i'm so
real that either third coffee i'd even
drink it oh that's that's actually not
real that's wasteful i didn't drink i
didn't mean to do it because kristen at
the airport duch is the kind of [ __ ]
person that gets a coffee after we land
we're waiting for the bags and she stops
at the starbucks we get all the bags
we're ready to leave and she's waiting
for not only her drink which would be
fine for my drink that i didn't even ask
her to get dude so then she brought it
and i was like i was like just don't
worry about it she's like well i already
paid for it she brought in the car and
then i'm in this [ __ ] internal battle
where it's like oh i should drink it
because she got it for me but i don't
really want it but should i prove a
point and [ __ ] not drink it or should
i prove a point to myself and just drink
it do you know what i'm saying
i do but i have a i have a solution for
you what
step one
[ __ ] chill out about it for sure
right on me
and step two
just do
the thing that you want to do whether
that's drink it or not drink it then
he's not himself but when you really
know you did you really know yourself do
you really know yourself in every aspect
of every situation you don't so that's
what i did i figured out myself i'm very
buddhist in this but when it came up you
knew if you wanted the coffee or not
right did you want the coffee i didn't
want it then then you don't drink it but
then she got it for me i'm like
and then i was like no
and in the car i was like looking at it
and it was just [ __ ] like the ice was
melting and i didn't even [ __ ] drink
it so this is my fourth coffee of the
day and the third one i drank so it's
your third coffee of the day
fourth coffee day but i only drank three
yeah third coffee of the day
i mean technically what we were talking
about if i ingested yesterday yeah
so it's your third okay okay should we
start yeah let's start okay great
most regular guy of all time what's up
matt and chris hope you guys are doing
well quick question for you today
starting a band with my friends we're
gonna play some rock and funk
blues
stuff like that i love it i recommend it
the spin moves
and they're on the fence about it so
any suggestions on your end would be
much appreciated thanks a lot
he wants to know if he should start a
band with his friends oh dude or the
name is starting a band with his friends
he wants to know if
he suggested the spin moves yeah as a
band name it's cool name they it sounds
like i don't think they liked it but
he's asking what should a band name be i
have it why i have what i i don't want
let's back up first of all the advice is
don't start a band with your friends
right why is that the advice because
it's gonna be bad
but that's how the beatles got started
and they were bad
okay
yeah yeah yeah she loves you yummy hey
yeah she loves you yeah yeah you're
[ __ ] such a [ __ ] brat we all live
in a yellow submarine no don't next okay
what do you want only literal lyrics
yes why that's the best dude but you can
think that's the best but to have only
literally is the best
and the worst
r b is the best music and the worst
music dude because they'll be like i'll
[ __ ] you in the [ __ ]
or they'll be like very frilly and like
super [ __ ] contrived but also
like uh give me an example
uh make it up or don't it doesn't matter
real song or not real song okay uh i
mean they would be it would be like oh
like they're [ __ ] like brian remember
the [ __ ] my feminist says oh oh my
god that was the hardest i've ever
laughed
when he's like a one where dad jump
rings from two
true i'd break a thing soon do whatever
the [ __ ] and there we bro he's just
counting basically yeah he is yeah right
so that's a bad song right
sounds kind of nice fat black people
love it i like brian mcknight my family
says like this thing like
yeah but but i'm just saying dude um
what are you saying like water runs dry
like that song dude with the boys to men
dude okay but what should the guy
the guy should
basically either start an r b band
okay okay that is strictly specific
or
not do a band
okay i don't like the advice of not
there you have it do a band he's not
asking that the beatles are bad
that's not what he's asking either okay
and and you're wrong but that's not what
he's asking either back up don't do a
boundary with your friends if you have
to do a band with your friends let's
take the let's say that yeah all right
if you have to do bad with your friends
then
name your band name your band not
something [ __ ] cute or stupid like
death cat for cuties okay okay there's
only or sparkle horses that's cab for
cutie not cuties who are you mom what
adding an s to whatever i know
pluralizing everything i know i know
mom won't be like get the chairs and
there's one chair and you lose your mind
and so uh
death cab for cutie or todd and the big
heads or whatever the [ __ ] that one is
big head todd
so stupid you it should literally like
the beatles is a great band name
it should all be the white stripes the
start it with the something okay spin
moves is good okay but the reptiles the
frogs take that one i never heard it
dogs dude you're bad at this no way i
would rock i'm in the frogs
i would start we're saying the beetles
because the b-e-e-t-o no no i'm saying
just it should be animals or something
and just
not left up to interpretation i have an
idea okay how about
animals or something
for the band the animals or something
nah maybe the animals no it's got to be
specific tigers
tigers that's nice
that's [ __ ] so stupid
wow
all right let's figure this out the
detroit tigers in the 90s anyway um does
blues
that's what he said one of the genres is
blues what was the other one he said he
did you said so many things
remember uh blues uh he said
uh
rock he said uh
uh something else i don't know but it
doesn't matter all music you know what
kind of music he's gonna make you know
you know what kind of music that guy's
gonna make how would you describe it
my silhouette is broken like that
[ __ ] the broken silhouettes
i just yeah i mean dude if you're
starting a band and you don't know what
to call it you're already [ __ ] no come
on get involved from jump dude
what get involved from jump from jump
hey guys i got an idea what are we doing
we're going to be the microphones and
these are the music we're going to kind
of play are you in or out dude be more
of a leader is he the also is he this
lead singer or is he the [ __ ]
guitarist we don't know
he knows
yeah i'm just saying
i don't i don't know what do you think
anthony
yeah
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say i'm not
gonna say inappropriately i'm not gonna
says
the singers that would be [ __ ] the
singers the singers and guitarists
the the the the blues singers we rock we
rock that's the name we rock okay we
rock [ __ ] you okay call it
that's good that's good
[ __ ] you the band that's good yup
yup [ __ ] you the band you breaking the
table no that's good [ __ ] you the band
[ __ ] you the band right okay [ __ ] you
the band that's the whole name right
mm-hmm yep and you see that guy come out
on stage is hilarious just in a flannel
that's true bass pro that's true uh hat
[ __ ] you the band all right cool great
next we got it
here we go
you want to read it sure oh this is a
returner holy [ __ ] the emojis and
everything hey again matt and chris i'm
back
in parentheses the one that wrote in
wrote in that i black out every time and
find out that i do the horizontal mambo
he blacks out and does we remember this
from a previous episode he blacks out
and doesn't remember that he has sex
until like a the the department next day
the partner
texts him hey that was great last night
and he was like
well i had sex like it's a [ __ ] what
was great like he doesn't even know yeah
he's like he's like it's a [ __ ]
what's his name movie what's the guy
from first viewer's day off matthew
matthew
matthew broderick like it's a matthew
broderick movie in the a in the 90s
anyway go ahead okay anyways i wanted to
i had sex with a question right that's
what the movie's called so go ahead
cutting me off so we did what stop doing
that okay but i'm just saying sarah
jessica parker's in it anyways i wanted
to add on to what i wrote last time
because i found out a little more about
the situation
[ __ ] uh oh well no but also that all
you could do is find out more about the
situation because yeah you don't know
anything about the situation because you
blacked out right so it turns out that
one of the girls i ran in
into bed that i ran into bed with was
actually my brother's ex-girlfriend of a
while
and now i seek for further advice
this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] my question
is do i tell my brother or keep it a
secret
also as chris said i drink because i
can't stop but also because it gives me
enjoyment okay well you don't really
need the second one if you have the
first one you know can't stop but also
it makes me happy okay you know um like
not i'm not a
like robin i can't stop robbing banks i
didn't know if this guy could
get like
darker
and he's done it yeah you know
well i mean he just he doesn't know like
he's just probably like he's got a bunch
of problems you know uh should you tell
your brother though that's the advice
should you tell your brother that you
had sex with his ex when you blacked out
and drank
okay in all honesty what i think he
should and let me tell you why okay
because
assuming you love he loves his brother
and cares what his brother thinks
obviously
something like that might
even though it's him doing it to himself
it could be this like self-inflicted
punishment that he needs
to feel like he's hit rock bottom he
needs to hit rock bottom it's like he's
doing the [ __ ] la like the right
catholics do like in the show servant
yeah or the girls on the ground and
self-flagellation
self-flagellation when she yeah she
thinks about oh i want [ __ ] dick and
she's like oh okay well whatever that's
actually you're adding that part right
yeah well what was it in that movie that
show i don't remember it wasn't i want
dick well if you if you're if you're
if you're having impure thoughts one of
those impure thoughts is if you're a
woman is i need that dick and then you
gotta go self-legitimate all i'm saying
is you made that part up well not no
yeah it for for what the show yeah but
also if you are a catholic and you start
thinking i need that [ __ ] dick
horizontally you gotta then go get the
[ __ ] cat of ninetales and
self-flagellate that is true but you
made it up that's all that's my only
thing i'm just saying it in religion the
priest would tell you to do that but go
ahead in religion you know uh
i think that you have to tell your
brother because your brother might
have a reaction that
makes you
really get your [ __ ] together and make
you make you obviously we didn't [ __ ]
help he's still doing it well well this
was also a follow-up i found out more
about the situation so maybe he did
stuff right right
well here's the thing if you stopped
you should tell them yeah
and say
frame it around gotta come clean i
didn't
i used to be like this and i've stopped
and i've i just i i've learned something
about one of my experiences when this
happened and whatever yeah and if you
haven't stopped yet i would i would say
there's even more of an imperative to
tell them because you need that rock
bottom to pad reasons for you to
motivate yourself to stop yeah
it's not just about drinking dude this
is [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] man
you're i mean i already went over this i
don't need to get all the way deep into
the thing that he does but this is
another level
it's not just another layer it's a whole
other level you [ __ ] your brother's
ex-girlfriend and mother's ex is a hoe
no yeah we're not forgetting that part
dude
she doing them both dude
that's fine she can do whatever she
wants well yeah but so can he
no that's different dude he's doing it
to his own brother she's just a woman in
the world she doesn't
necessarily need to like be
that's not on what planet is it not hoey
to [ __ ] brothers
i don't know this this planet yeah yeah
yeah years between come on years between
what what if it's years between oh it's
years between yeah i mean i guess but
then okay if it doesn't matter and it's
years between then why is he coming up
with it
you're saying because it's his brother
and he should come clean yeah also
here's the other thing too what if they
were like what if like when he was drunk
and blacked out she didn't know he was
blacked out and she was like we're not
gonna tell anyone he's like yup we're
not gonna tell everyone anyone even your
brother and he's like yup and then he
does the horizon to mambo and then now
he's feeling guilty and he's like well i
gotta tell him but they already agreed
on the [ __ ] that dude this [ __ ]
[ __ ] up he's got to eat it yeah eat it
eat it change because it's inside you
and that shit's going to become cancer
okay but you got to eat that [ __ ] man if
you made a pact with the chick also if
you're very close with the brother you
gotta i can't imagine doing that to you
and not telling you you gotta say yeah
true
true you gotta say it's all also it's
it's there's so many things going on
here wow this guy's in trouble yeah yeah
but
change
i think my advice to you is change
change you know yeah you're living
you're living not it's not a right the
right way right because the black and
white change the blacking out thing
alone is one thing that's [ __ ] up you
should get help they're blacking out and
having sex and not remembering it at all
big problem is real bad he's real bad
yeah yeah yeah forgetting the donkey and
then absolutely
i also think he should talk to this
woman and be like what was i like yeah
good good
good happened like what the [ __ ]
happened good advice i give good advice
too but that's good advice okay
yeah and that's so good i think you
gotta tell them and that's that's the
end of it but go to her first and say yo
i'm going to tell my brother how about
that well that's yes yes because you
can't blindside her it sucks dude you
both did this that's a that's [ __ ] yeah
you're that's you're right you got to
talk to her first yeah yes dude i got
one one you did get one one to one yeah
all right go ahead
next yo what's up
what's up matt big fan i'm so glad you
guys are doing this pod oh yeah so here
here's my dilemma um how do i take your
seatbelt off that is a serial cheater uh
she cheats on her boyfriend all the time
and i don't know her boyfriend that well
but when i did meet him he seems like
just the nicest guy in the world
and she has nothing but great things to
say about him
and i'm curious on what
i should do about this if anything um
you know i hate to that he has to go
through this
unknowingly um i've told her plenty of
times that she should just be single she
obviously doesn't want that
and uh
you know to make matters worse they have
a family together they have kids so you
know i don't know maybe it's just not my
place i should just stay out of it
um
but you know she tells me this these
stories of her you know messing around
with these other guys
and i can't help but feel bad for the
guy especially when i see him
and you know we we all hang out as a
group
and you you know it's just a dilemma
and i'm wondering if i should play any
part of this at all
or just ignore it
and live my own life like i've been
doing
let me know what you think thanks
i feel like
you know he's friends with her i don't
know how close he is with her sounds
like they're close but he he's
definitely not close with him you can
tell yeah no there he's just met him a
few times so it's not like you're his
friend it's like you're her friend yes
you don't
you don't know their relationship 100
my i'm always like you got to let people
live their path and figure out what they
are figure out their own lives
especially they have a family
yeah you got to let them bump into the
wall on their own yeah all right but
what i think is
first things first if he was his friend
it'd be a different story right first
things first
i would say
talk to her about it and it makes but
base it around like you in a way like
this makes me uncomfortable i don't i
don't know and like and see what she
says but he's already done that and
she's he he says she's brought it up
yeah well he said like yo maybe you
should just be single but he has maybe
he probably hasn't had a real sit down
with her you know i think the thing also
is that he needs to say
stop telling me about this [ __ ] oh yeah
for sure like why are you telling me
because it's making him uncomfortable
and then he meets the guy and he's like
yeah
he's like [ __ ] philip seymour hoffman
in the big lebowski he's like
oh hi
you know what i mean totally dude and i
think that that why
why is she i think that's something
worth examining on its own why the [ __ ]
is she telling you about this [ __ ] like
is it what's her tone is she confessing
is she ashamed that's one thing but if
she's just like yeah i [ __ ] messed
around with this guy and like i i i you
don't want to hear that [ __ ] and so i'm
giving this is this is like protection
for you i'm giving you advice i don't
know her oh yeah and i don't know the
guy the advice we don't know him really
about it's the [ __ ] yeah but he's
asking for trust and it's about his life
dude tell her to [ __ ] stop telling
you about this [ __ ] and then also ask
her why the [ __ ] do you tell me in the
first place like what the like like why
why are you
airing this out to me
like what do you think is what are you
getting out of it like also this is all
all of this makes me uncomfortable when
you tell me about it it makes me
uncomfortable so stop telling me if you
care about our friendship stop making me
uncomfortable yeah just be yeah he could
be like i don't really want to be a part
of this yeah you know that that's the
main thing yes but i don't think you i
mean if you go and you talk to the guy
you barely know him i mean the guy could
have a reaction like [ __ ] you stay out
of her business you know but i think if
he's gonna do anything like that he
should talk to her yes that's the key
and say like you know what to come clean
honestly tell the kids first
no i think that you you talk to her is
the main thing and you say yo just so
you know i don't like when you talk
about this [ __ ] with me yeah just keep
your side of the street clean right yeah
i think that's the main the main goal
yeah and then it might turn into a
conversation where
you have an opening to like not judge
her right but like
ask her like why a few things why you
tell she tells you in the first place
but also why maybe she does it or or
whatever maybe she he'll glean something
that
yeah i don't i mean i doubt they have an
open relationship yeah what he's saying
but you i don't know and so
i just think that
limiting this to being about you and not
passing judgment on anyone tell her it
makes you uncomfortable yeah and that
you don't want to hear about it anymore
i wonder how she tells them too like
they're just homies that's what i'm
saying it's [ __ ] weird dude she's
just like yo we're still on for dinner
and then she's like yeah i'll see you at
five i gotta suck a dick at 4 30. you
know like i really wonder what it is
about the guy's just
like i really wonder how she tells him
yeah so it sounds like there's multiple
instances it could be guys yeah you know
because it was once or twice he probably
wouldn't call into maybe it's like an
affair a single affair
yeah that's that's also that would make
it different too yeah that makes it
different i mean if it's multiple dudes
if she's just out there [ __ ] with her
mouth open you know right like on
[ __ ] a street corner
also dude the guy with her mouth open is
uh is that an expression no wow okay
yeah i make up expressions my babies
okay so maybe he's like on this like but
also he's playing it real close here
like doing it on my flight dude like
hundreds of thousands of people are
gonna see this and uh and somebody's
going to see it and the the boyfriend
might see it the boyfriend's probably a
huge fan of ours he probably is yeah and
so he's going to be like wait a minute
yep
and you know he thought about that
yeah you know well
hopefully it's all okay and everything
works out so basic so basically but i
hope that [ __ ] you know this could
lead to a [ __ ] murder life this
because this is on this podcast this
could lead to a [ __ ] homicide okay
relax i'm just dude you got to think of
all angles and then also i'll turn on
like [ __ ] fear thy neighbor and then
it'll be like oh [ __ ] and we'll be on it
what's fear the neighbor
it's where like a neighbor goes bonkers
and shoots everybody in the [ __ ]
shoots their neighbors it's a show yeah
it's a [ __ ] and dramatization there's a
show about
there's enough neighbors killing
neighbors that there's shows yeah fear
thy neighbor and then there's fear thy
roommate
no yeah and there's fear that i mean
everyone's out there killing each other
dude sounds like it huh they're making
fear thy [ __ ] home depot and play
um but yeah dude everyone's out there
killing each other dude so be careful
man you don't want this to lead to a
[ __ ] homicide is my point i mean
obviously yeah but dude he's [ __ ] i'm
telling you man you don't want to be in
[ __ ] fear of my name or season five
and we might be in fear that
neighborhood season five because a
[ __ ] timberland look like came in and
did this [ __ ] video yeah
yeah we'll be interviewed for it and
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying and they
seem like i saw footage archive footage
of this [ __ ] he seemed like a nice guy
you know like that yeah exactly
when there's a murderer dude i'll tell
you something man because it's always
that unless they make a whole
documentary that's a mini series and
then it's like yeah he always he was
very creepy right like if it's just one
episode about a guy it's always yeah it
was weird they'd come in and he was nice
we didn't have any [ __ ] idea but bro
if you're talking about a guy that's
like like they'd spend time on those
[ __ ] and documentaries yeah
like if it was john wayne gacy everyone
kind of knew they were like gabe boasted
all the time he was very weird john my
gesture was
even like you start to dig about that
guy i know it just gets weirder i know
that's exactly right yeah although also
if you didn't know that somebody was a
serial killer and you knew them you're a
[ __ ] idiot
like let's just say that say that again
everyone's always like we had no idea
right how about this you're a [ __ ]
idiot you know what i think all the time
i think a person's a serial killer yeah
i know that's what i'm saying that's
what you're saying it's like and like
you're wrong half the time but you air
on the side i've always probably got
bodies you're wrong way more than half
the time
you know there's not that many [ __ ]
serial killers but yeah i think about
you like that that's like you know who
dude if anyone in my life was a serial
killer and then it gets exposed yeah and
then they're like did you ever i'm gonna
be like oh yeah no i could definitely
say i was that guy
you're [ __ ] the only person in the
history though yeah but they wouldn't
use my footage because they wanted to
seem like the [ __ ] drastic difference
right right right right i knew
[ __ ] yeah it's so obvious look
at we buttons all the way up with his
crazy glasses yeah right yeah buying
roses for girls he barely knows right
yeah all right dude so next all right
next
what's up matt what's up chris
so i got this friend
who
uh he was a groomsman at my wedding i
flaked on the rehearsal
i invited him to my daughter's first
birthday flaked on that
jesus and then
well before that was my bachelor party i
invited him uh to that was super stoked
for him to come out
and he flaked on that god and he
didn't have any excuses for all these
times that he's flaked on these huge
moments in my life
he just didn't show up i've confronted
this guy my best friend and i've been
friends with him
since middle school and i'm 28 now so
i don't know however long that is
over a decade
trying to figure out um
whether to keep him around in my life or
not
every time i see him now he's like
says how much he
you know loves hanging out with me and
how he misses me and
you know we always have a good time
hanging out but i always have uh
always kind of eats at me a little bit
all those things that he didn't show up
for me for yeah no [ __ ] um because those
are
i think those are pretty important
things and you know i trusted him wanted
him to be there for me and he wasn't you
know especially for my daughter's
birthday that that was kind of yeah kind
of the nail in the coffin for me so
i'm just trying to figure out
whether
i should keep him in my life or not
whether he's even more worth my time
because i don't think i'll ever
you know i've kind of forgiven him but i
don't know if i'll ever forget those
things you know so am i being too
dramatic should i let it go and
move on try to try to figure it out with
him or
has he done enough to where
i should just just cut him off you know
he's not even worth it anymore
so any advice would be appreciated
thanks guys cool i think that maybe like
it's like one of those things was like
should i keep him in my life
uh any anymore when it's like he's
already making that decision for you
he's not in your life because he's not
coming to the [ __ ] important things
these things are you know like i dude i
i had to figure this out too like you
know
people want you there for certain things
and if you're not there you know once is
fine twice okay but then you're just an
[ __ ] like you know if people are
constantly not showing up for you in
your life then what is a friend somebody
you text with somebody you just run into
at the bar somebody that you get lunch
with this is your wedding this is your
[ __ ] uh daughter's birthday like i
have people that i have people like that
in my life where i'm just like okay
you know i have i have one buddy that
just called me and he was like i'm not
gonna be able to come to your wedding
and i'm like all right that's kind of
the last straw dude you know like i love
you bud but like you obviously don't
want to be a part of my life anymore you
know and it's different case by case but
i think that i think that dude it's just
uh
i don't know man i mean he's answering
your question for you yeah i i actually
i should say i'm
i'm not like this like when people don't
want to come to [ __ ] that
of mine i don't ever care
because i understand
why people wouldn't want to go to a
thing because i don't want to go to hell
yeah but people aren't like you but that
being said i totally understand where
this guy's coming from and i way
understand very very very much
understand that i'm in the minority in
that way yeah yeah so that being said i
think that
you should at least
explain
to him or not give him another chance
but like
let him know what's going on right and
if you're gonna as you say cut him out
that's totally your prerogative but i i
think you should at least uh tell him
and not just like stop entirely
contacting this guy yeah i guess so yeah
yeah then he's gonna be like hey dude
yeah yeah then you're maybe the bad guy
yeah but also also people grow people
change and then friends you gotta treat
them like an army like sometimes people
are front line [ __ ] you put the
idiots up there right that was gonna
shut the [ __ ] up and the generals are
gonna be good in the back but you also
need the generals right you need the
generals and those people to make
decisions with those people that come to
your [ __ ] daughter's birthday party
right and then you got the [ __ ] guys
who fled the planes you got all the
other [ __ ] you got the navy you
got the [ __ ] you know
and maybe this guy is just a frontline
[ __ ] that is is supposed to get
popped right away right you got to have
those guys in your life right yeah you
got to have those guys when the
drawbridge opens on the beaches of
normandy and just [ __ ]
pop that's this dude and he just goes
all right you know maybe your friend is
the guy looking for his arm and saving
private ryan so disrespectful to the
fallen but
but no what i think is you you can also
there's another option which is
to sort of like reconsider
recontextualize how good of a friend
this guy is you don't it's not either
he's this amazing friend who comes to
your daughter's birthdays or i don't
talk to this [ __ ] at all
if he's a front seat friend if he was he
can be a backseat friend now he doesn't
need to be
front seat friend or he's out of the
[ __ ] car do you know what i'm saying
like he can just be a different kind of
you kind what i was saying but in a
different way better well i was doing it
with the army [ __ ] way right but i'm
doing it i'm doing it a little bit with
a bitch-ass car like a [ __ ]
dodge knee
no car a car
i'm sticking with the car metaphor yeah
yeah go buy his house drive by and and
[ __ ] when you and when he pops honk
the horn when he pops his head out the
window just go like this hit the windows
down and go like this
wow what what like you were up here oh
and now you're down here so you think
that motherfucker's gonna understand no
i don't oh i think he'll call him
afterwards and be like what the [ __ ] was
that all about and then was that you
like what the [ __ ] he's gonna say i was
just showing you where you were and now
where you are
if you'd like to make a call please hang
up and try again
message c5 taking it so far digging so
far remember that [ __ ] no what's message
c5 they would do that at the end on the
[ __ ] land lines yeah and then it was
[ __ ] it would happen so it would go
you would hang up and then we'll go and
then we'll go
and then you know
let you know it's off the hook really
loudly and then if you left that going
in the 90s it would say
message c5 yeah whatever the [ __ ] i i
don't i've never heard that a boy likes
to see what the [ __ ] happens when i
leave [ __ ] alone and i think you're
lying
okay i'm not lying okay well i decided
that you are okay well that's what makes
you wrong one of us has to be nope
all right next one
hi matt hi chris i mean the tick tock my
question to you guys is
what would you suggest i do in a
situation where i was seeing somebody
quite a long time ago
beginning of the year
didn't last very long
no longer seeing each other
nothing dramatic happened
for the parting of ways
prior to hooking up
loose friends have a lot of mutual
friends however
it's becoming apparent that this person
is trying to keep a connection
keep going you're not really getting the
hint i'm trying to sort of let it
die it doesn't seem to be working
and at what point
do i swing the hammer and say something
that's
forceful or do i just continue to
hope that
they'll get the hint through
non-engagement
uh are you
uh guys don't take uh hint very well
yeah they don't take a hit very well and
you gotta and they always and guys are
always like i wish these [ __ ] chicks
would just tell so just [ __ ] tell
them also what's with the [ __ ] tick
tock that's hilarious what's the tick
and also in the back was there like an
animal drinking there was a dog drink of
water yeah yeah i'm very perceptive and
i knew that before you no i knew it
before you okay so um yeah i mean you
don't like this guy like that you know
you had sex or whatever you hooked up
and then
he wanted to be friends and you just you
got the ick or whatever the [ __ ] people
from australia say right she's like
yeah what do you mean
what the [ __ ] do you think she's not
from the midwest
you know why she's you know why she's
australian but besides the accent
because she's from australia no besides
that she's got a lot of tattoos dude
austria you can find somebody with no
tattoos on australia you can't they're
[ __ ] two years old at three they're
like yeah i'll get a pacifier
yeah if i get i look to get a [ __ ]
i want to get a paw patrol across my
chest i swear to god dude you cannot
find a [ __ ] australian without 90
tattoos it's unbelievable okay okay so
that's how you know she's just trying to
show the voice okay and um
yeah dude just you gotta
i don't i i don't know man it's like
don't it's like
this guy wants to look you're attractive
he had sex with you he wants to probably
keep you in the rotation right he
probably is because he unless cause it
doesn't sound like you guys wanted to be
boyfriend or girlfriend right the guy
probably wants to keep you around but
you know he wants the milk but he
doesn't want to [ __ ] buy the cow
right okay or whatever that ex whatever
that's saying is it ain't that but yeah
whatever the saying whatever whatever
the saying is that my ex's mom would say
to me once on the phone and that got me
really hot and bought really uh
sorry wrong wrong thing but um
yeah man just tell him you know look
you're australian so look him right in
the eye and when he says hey wanna hang
out since you're australian look him
right in the eye and say
no
so many sounds in the world
wow
okay and get a tattoo
you know what get a tattoo across your
[ __ ] forehead that says otto and i
hang out with you no yeah just just nah
no
[ __ ] whatever his name is 12 letters
no
uh no i think that you just [ __ ] tell
him you don't have to be that night you
have to be nice in this world you don't
have to like bend over backwards break
your [ __ ] back nice just be like uh
hey
i i this is not the thing for me
has every you know what has it happened
to you i one time a girl said something
to me uh what happened to me this like
where you're like oh i thought we were
going to do this again but i realized
she didn't want to oh like am i have i
been in his the guys before yeah
trust me like before i even say this
like dude i lay it down trust me okay
okay okay so this doesn't happen a lot
okay relax what i'm saying but i lay it
down i'm sure here's what i'll say i'm
sure it has i cannot think of a time but
i probably can't remember one of mine
either but i i do it does ever come to
mind because it probably hasn't happened
but it has once
but i lay it down right okay but i'm
being serious i'm sure that's happening
but i can't think of one but i remember
one time i was like yeah we're gonna
hang out and i remember what this girl
said and i was like fair enough man she
said oh that ship has sailed oh yeah and
i was like huh
fair enough for sure that's the right
response and i was like all right cool
yeah whatever so just say that ship is
sailed that sheep is siled yeah i i i
respect the [ __ ] out of people who do
that stuff by the way anyway even if
it's bad news for me if they just come
right out and [ __ ] say it i'm like
well damn okay
do you know what you [ __ ] think how
you feel
now i know too and i can move [ __ ] on
accordingly yep it's way better to tell
him just tell him it's better for him
too or how about this dude how about
this hey guy
be sexier
be [ __ ] undeniably cool how about
that dude you're not she doesn't want
you bro if you were don juan de
[ __ ]
uh perth or wherever the [ __ ] you're
from
wow if you were don juan de adelaide
then you know what dude you wouldn't be
having this problem and this chick would
not be saying no
she'd be saying yeah
well that is how they say it yeah right
yeah
but also
that is not a thing that's possible
being sexier are you kidding me have you
seen my sexier recently i've seen the
way i walk it's way different than how i
used to and it's a lot better no i
haven't and no it's not
no i haven't and no it's not ask kristen
nope
uh no but but
the
bottom [ __ ] line
the middle line the top line and the
bottom line all say the same thing weird
which is tell him weird order middle
line the top line there's a line in the
middle of the top mid to top line bottom
middle line and then bottom line is
every line
every line says one thing okay tell him
tell him i don't want to hang out
anymore yeah busy in the tier 2 parlor
getting titties okay you're taking a
little [ __ ] fart
that's not accurate anymore dead ship
has sailed getting his ship on me back
getting a ship on my back yeah because
it's sailed
the ship's got your name on it
it's far away it's a little ship in me
on my back and it's far far away because
it sailed
my
she would he would be like oh my god
that would do the trick he would want to
stop texting the answer is hey guy be
sexier honestly no dude the advice isn't
for the [ __ ] guy dude
but if it was she wouldn't even have
this question if if what was if what if
we gave that guy advice hey guy call in
where are you dude yeah he should have
been calling him hey man i really want
to hang out i really want to hang out
with this ch chick you know i was really
awesome really had a great time she
makes me split i don't know um here to
get her back but like she seems like she
wants to be friends but like i'm really
interested in [ __ ] squirting and like
i don't know how to do it
squinting be sexier bro dude develop a
new one thing you can do differently you
can't just be a sexy person yes you can
dude i do it like every ten months okay
okay okay all right
next one
what's up chris and matt nice uh love
you guys love the show got you some
great advice
and i'll give you a little context on my
issue we've been hanging out with this
dude and his wife
for a while you know
like five or six months right we all
became pretty close they integrated to
our friendship friend group really well
and
um not too long ago we found out that he
was
beating her right
hitting her
you know
verbally abusing her
and when we first heard about it we
never really witnessed it
so we just told him like hey
you got to stop
we're going to kick your ass right this
is not good
needs to be over but it's happened again
so at this point i've completely written
this guy off he's not my friend anymore
and um
jesus i really want to just kick this
guy's teeth in right you know teach him
a lesson
but part of me
maybe the more rational side of me
thanks
you know i'm all i'm already in
some trouble with the military
i
so i really should just kind of lay low
at this point
but
trouble with the mobility
really just wants
to kick
the [ __ ] out of this guy
you know i'll do a spin move
and knock him out i don't care that's
about playing my imaginary mandolin
and kick his teeth down his throat like
i'm
tired of this guy
i just wanted to know what y'all would
do in my situation
um
should i go through with it should i err
on the side of caution
um
that's it all right i mean imagine if
that's what he did
wow imagine if that's what he did he
just [ __ ]
and then just continued to kick this
[ __ ] out
hold on dude you're not okay look this
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] up situation
terrible but you're not batman
you can't so you don't just go kick the
[ __ ] out of somebody also you'll go to
[ __ ] jail yeah this guy should go to
jail if that's what's happening this
other guy should that's what i was going
to say so just call the cops yeah i mean
obviously it's on her she's gotta you
gotta talk to her about it yeah but like
because you can't do a thing that she
doesn't want you to do you gotta listen
to what the woman
wants and that's complicated but you
have to um
that being said you you can't kick the
[ __ ] out of him oh yeah because then you
would end up in jail yeah but also what
if you lose
oh you really think
and then just like right before he even
gets a shot off but something tells me
that this guy
can kick the [ __ ] out of many many many
because he's in trouble with the miller
any guy that's in trouble with the
military yeah also
i mean how did he just sneak that in
there by the way i'm already in trouble
with the military he's in the military
or he's the taliban no man he's in the
military i'm saying or he did 911. no
you don't get in trouble with the
military if you're the taliban is in
trouble with the military they are but
that's not what you [ __ ] say okay i'm
just saying he wouldn't say he was in
the taliban he like had to go to the
brig or some [ __ ] he's like in trouble
like maybe he went awol something like
that maybe or not a [ __ ] terrorist he
could be isis i'm just saying all right
anyway
it looked like an isis video he was you
know what i mean right sounds a voice
too by holding somebody's head
zooms out
uh wait no it's a guy's head you got
you're already if you're already in
trouble legally with some part yeah the
branch of the united states government
yes even more you can't kick the [ __ ]
out of this [ __ ] guy but i see why
you think that way you know why because
you think that way and your history
proves it so don't do what you do yeah
right sit back relax talk to this woman
yeah try to get her to [ __ ] call the
police yes because this is a violent
crime yes i mean this isn't like hey
this guy keeps stealing my money yeah or
like [ __ ] taking taking my lunch
money right this is a guy beats this
[ __ ] out of a woman which is [ __ ] up
in any way yeah so yeah
uh
yeah dude i mean that is a first of all
that's such a terrible [ __ ] situation
for you yeah we joke around a lot but
that's [ __ ] that's not the situation
anybody should have to find themselves
in this for that woman first of all
but
something like that is it makes so many
waves and [ __ ] touches on so many
other things outside of the one [ __ ]
unit of people it's just so bad for
everybody involved but you gotta get you
gotta
not kick the share of this guy
you gotta restrain yourself in that
department although i can relate i would
wanna do the same i do want to do the
same i don't even [ __ ] know this guy
but he deserves to get the [ __ ] kicked
out of him but
you can't do it so you will not do it
you will talk to this woman and you will
try to
first of all be open to what she has to
say don't be like you got to go to the
[ __ ] cops you got to do it now yeah
talk to her hear what she has to say and
try to navigate the conversation in such
a way that it becomes a conversation
about
going to the authorities in some
capacity because
he is not going to stop doing it no he's
not going to just be like if there's no
consequence certainly he's not going to
stop take him on springer
yeah but take him on jerry springer yeah
but no you know what i mean cause you
could beat the [ __ ] out of people on
that show and for some reason nobody
ever gets arrested yeah that's true
actually um wow that's a heavy one man
jesus christ
talk to her
restrain yourself in terms of physical
violence talk to her and try desperately
to
get her
to to to to to to want to go to the
authorities you know you do put kilos of
coke in his trunk and then call the cops
anonymously and be like i know this guy
is distributing drugs and then that guy
gets in huge trouble and the girl won't
get beaten anymore you got to think
outside the box dude well that's way
outside the box but uh i wouldn't
recommend that i would recommend what i
said we'll see
uh
but i understand why you'd want to kick
the [ __ ] out of this yeah talk to her
first the worst [ __ ] thing you can do
talk to her first if she doesn't want to
you know she's like no i love him and
you know she's like in one of those
relationships yeah yeah then [ __ ]
plant some kilos of coke and it's in the
back of his [ __ ] goddamn chevelle or
whatever it is call the cops wow cops i
got a hot tip can't tell you who will
you know do the [ __ ] taliban thing
right
well that makes me mad it makes me mad
what does the taliban thing no man not
you the the guy [ __ ] said
uh
yeah [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up well maybe we got another one
i mean so made us well like that this
way guys my name is jet i'm 22
i'm in college and
um i have a question about
how to sort of control
um the universe you're in your mind um
this is anger in relation to an idea
that chris has talked about on his
podcast where
he makes up fake scenarios in his head
oh yeah just so he can get mad at them
yeah um
like he'll make up a fake argument and
then like what he'll say in the fake
argument and it just gets like
super worked up and i i found that i do
the same thing i think it's pretty cool
um
and it does feel good to indulge
yourself into those fake scenarios and
get angry and you know anger sometimes
feels really good but
um
i was wondering um if there's a way to
stop that because it's starting to
affect how i see people in real life
like if i have a fake argument with my
friend in my head or something then i
start to like genuinely like have
negative feelings towards them and it's
like it's like not
um
good something that
should be happening so i was just
curious like chris i know you've
struggled with this um and maybe
you've figured out a way to put a stop
to it you definitely haven't um but i'd
love to
hear your thoughts on it
matt as well um
thank you so much cool i mean i would
suggest working out and getting that
address uh aggression out but it looks
like he's fit he probably does work out
he is fine he definitely serves there's
no doubt in
well here's the thing he's 20 what do
you say 222 that's really really young
to already think that like you only get
angrier
like you only get angrier unless you're
thinking about it which i guess he is
thinking about it you know hopefully
he's talking to somebody about his anger
i mean but like dude i'm in the car all
day long and i i'll just
out of nowhere i'll be like oh you think
so you know what i mean and then off and
by the way i don't even know who i'm at
yet and then i'll pick one of my friends
and i'll be like that's who it is today
yeah i do that and then i do understand
so you're crazy you're a crazy guy well
yeah i mean i think more people do that
i think more people do that than i think
you probably do that ah i think you talk
to yourself in your car and you imagine
arguments that you get into sometimes i
think well one time i was driving down
the street and i was doing it i looked
next to me and i got a guy was [ __ ]
doing it to another guy one of his
friends i wonder if it was the same
friend i don't i don't think i've done
that i do crazy [ __ ] not that though
mm-hmm um but this guy's let me get this
straight because he's talking about you
that's what you do yeah you talk about
having fake arguments for people to like
get it out like get out of your way yeah
like well no not even necessarily but
like i'll be
[Music]
like okay take something that your
friend does like take like say you have
a friend that's always late
okay and you're you'll be in you know he
says in the car but you can do it
anywhere right you're just daydreaming
and you're like okay like say my the guy
i bring on the road with me michael
noche say he's always late he's not but
[Music]
we if we have a gig say this weekend in
atlanta we'll be like oh
i'll be thinking about it and i'll be
like oh they better not be [ __ ] late
right and then i'll be like because he's
always [ __ ] late and then i'll be
like in atlanta in my mind he'll be
showing up
and i'll be like it's [ __ ] late and
in my head and i'm driving i'm in the
car and i'm just like i can't believe
you're [ __ ] late again now it's me
all of a sudden i'm saying it out loud i
can't believe you're [ __ ] late again
and then i'll do his part in my head and
then i'll be like you know what if you
and i'll come up with ideas of how the
conversation is going to go if it
happens in atlanta and then i'm all
[ __ ] riled up yeah and then either it
happens or it doesn't that weekend in
atlanta and if it does happen if it
doesn't happen it's [ __ ] [ __ ] i
shouldn't have got all that out in the
car anyway yes because now i'm feeling
angry at him or it does happen in
atlanta and i think i know what to say
but he's not going to say what i think i
s
yeah exactly because conversation he's a
different person yeah so it's but so i
you know i don't know if it's good or
bad that i do it but i'm in my car
having these conversations and i'm
really sticking it to him man and i'm
doing real good you know i'm doing real
good in my head i'm winning the argument
but mostly because it's in my head and
he's saying the things that i want him
to say that i know how to come back well
if he says this i'll say that if he says
this i'll say that right
you need help
i'm getting it you need help getting
maybe you need a little bit more help
but i think that maybe a more like
controlled way to do this one that
doesn't increase rage is to like write
it out as if it was a letter and contain
your thoughts in a way that is like a
persuasive argument thoughtful and you
think it all the way through
and then you never send it that's what a
lot of therapists would tell you oh
really yeah i actually have done that
and let me tell you it actually works
you'll start to like forget about it but
because you've gotten it out it's a
weird mind trick i'm not saying like
it's like some actual woohoo [ __ ] it
doesn't nothing actually changes yeah
except something about writing it down
walking through the whole part of like
expressing it as if you were gonna
export to that person
it even makes it like easier on
you become easier on that person my
therapist always tells me to do that i
never do it do it
but it's like i don't want to write an
essay you know i'm not you don't write
an essay you write an email and you
don't send it you don't send it i mean
obviously you don't send it back it
seems a little risky writing an email
you don't put your name in the [ __ ]
thing okay but if you just by mistake
hit that one button dude then you don't
write it off to mike linoche subject
later you're always late and then save
it as here's why you're a [ __ ] one two
three four five seconds exactly yeah
well all right look i mean we we have
more videos and we're not going to stop
yet but i do want to say since i forgot
to do this i will be in atlanta wow
wow
september 9th crystallia.com uh i'll be
in atlanta september 9th
washington dc september 10th this is an
ad break i guess stockton california
oakland i got dates in you know superior
illinois rockford made it up uh raleigh
october 21st savannah georgia denver
november 5th cheyenne wyoming november
6. boston almost sold out november 12th
jacksonville florida december 3rd so go
to chrislea.com and get those tickets
now there's still tickets available on
uh all of their shows as of now they're
big places um so uh yeah let's do it we
can do one more video all right and then
we're done
hey guys first time caller long time
listener love the new show
today i'm going to be using missed
connection
lingo as a way to describe this scenario
also this is completely hypothetical not
saying this has ever happened to me um
so let's just say a 24 year old male
plumber
has been on this web okay a hundred
percent happened yes okay we know that
yes also let me explain if you haven't
seen my podcast congratulations i do a
segment called miss connections where i
read miss connections from craigslist
and i just go through them and they're
always about [ __ ] sex and they're
trying to
um
like what do you call it they're trying
to not
they you they like i don't know why i
guess they get flagged if they talk
about like blow jobs so they'll be like
i want to eat your corn on the cob no
yeah it's really funny
wow people are so [ __ ] i know crazy
and weird man
they'll be like mexican chub
what is that like a fat mexican i want a
fat mexican
to come over to my house and clean my
pipes it'd be like mexican chub come
clean my pipes that sounds like a way to
get real crossed up oh well somebody
comes to your door with plumbing
equipment they should if
yeah well not just go to a plumber i
guess if you were gonna true yeah all
right so go ahead
hey guys first time caller long time
listener love the new show
today i'm going to be using missed
connection lingo as a way to describe
this scenario also this is completely
hypothetical
not saying this has ever happened to me
so let's just say a 24 year old male
plumber has been on this website where
he is looking for prospective female
clients
uh also interested in plumbing and pipe
cleaning
he's been messaging this one female
client back and forth and she finally
invites him back to her place
and they start to do some plumbing and
during the pipe cleaning the male
plumber's part or tool
stops performing
or malfunctions
what would you recommend the male
plumber to do in this scenario
what could he say to the female client
in order to assure her that it's not her
fault
thank you looking forward to what you
guys have to say uh and yes i recorded
this in a bomb shelter
dude how weird is that that that was the
[ __ ] thing that i said and then he
did that very weird i'm psychic dude are
you know what it is i'm great
you know obviously it's like the
funniest version of it
or the hackiest which is why we both
came like a professional comedian i am
and that's the one i went now you guys
are hacked he's a plumber you're right
you are happy no so all right so he
is obviously talking about himself the
answer is make a [ __ ] joke about it
no you go like this it's your fault do a
spin move and [ __ ] move he just said
how do i make sure that to tell her that
it's not her fault it is okay no it's
not i'm kidding it's not dude i'm joking
we do jokes here um
yeah well i mean yeah make a [ __ ]
joke about it dude make a joke about
what you could say what this is for real
because it's happened to me what
if you say you know
this is true this is well for me it's
been true in my life i'm 42 it's
happened but i'm like you know
uh
i i actually like you and i'm like
it's not that i'm nervous but like i i
want you to like me and i want to make
sure that everything is cool
and that's why
was that true yes for me oh well if it
was true i like the girl
the first time a lot of the times it's
like um i don't
i'm not fully
you know what i mean it's like you're
ripped up a little in your head you mean
i guess
like a little i mean like i guess so
butterflies i don't feel nervous but
it's like it's like but it's a nervous
system thing yes yes but the thing is
i'm not a [ __ ] dude oh and if you're
thinking that that's not true at all
okay right
again thank you one more time relax yeah
but i would say that that's a and i have
said that to the girl that's good
actually because it's it's honest and
endearing and it makes it clear
which checks this box which this guy's
concerned with which is actually very
thoughtful he wants to make sure that
the woman knows it's not her fault right
or not her not fault but like not
because he's not attracted to her let's
say
uh
but
uh
so yeah there's there's that but i think
there's also
when i say make a joke i don't mean like
about
her
obviously like a joke about like a
self-deprecating joke about yourself
about something
faulty hardware [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] but uh
yeah dude it's so
[ __ ]
obvious
the thing
the things not to not do are so [ __ ]
obvious yeah you know what i mean like
you don't want to [ __ ]
make anything that's even remotely
possibly
misconstrued as you were
blaming
her that would be sayonara to you for
the rest of your [ __ ]
time on earth with this particular woman
yeah or you could be like some guys like
some guys like uh but you remember in
that
movie um
the one with the [ __ ] ben stiller and
the guy who goes with my baseball and
cameron diaz oh something about mary
yeah um he
jerks off before he goes on a date right
yeah yeah yeah you know you could just
say you did that oh but that see that
here's something sometimes there are
dire situations where you really want to
save someone's feelings where the only
thing you can think of in the moment is
to lie yeah
i don't think that you have to do that
in this situation because true the truth
is not only endearing but uh also the
truth and the truth is always a little
easier or a lot easier
because you don't have to remember the
thing you [ __ ] like oh man but then
it's like [ __ ] if it happens the next
time dude then you're in your head you
know what i mean right but then at least
it would be like a
the last the previous case would be true
and then that would be like
a rolling
truth i guess
like it's just perpetuating itself and
then it becomes its thing i get what
you're saying about getting in your head
but you don't want to lie yeah yeah yeah
or you could maybe you're gay
you think he's gay no i mean he might be
just be like you know what i haven't
decided if i'm into dudes yet or not but
this is really good though thank you
sorry
we'll see you next time
that would be the worst thing to say i'm
gonna [ __ ] a guy next and then when i
come back to you we'll see what happens
yeah
yeah i mean that's an option i wouldn't
recommend it but you could go that way
um
yeah tell her what i said dude that's
good because that's probably how you
feel i'm a psychiatrist oh okay uh if
that's the truth then definitely do what
he said because that's good yeah um all
right cool well that was good that was
great um
that's it we'll wrap it up we did like
eight videos uh chrisleya.com for
tickets i got i got a bunch of cities
coming up i read them about 10 minutes
ago uh so go get your tickets now still
some seats available and uh and that's
it did we have anything oh did you pull
up the the the [ __ ] home screen or no
if you have a
if you have a uh a question go to uh
what do you call it um
what is it anthony
do you know it did you ask matt and
chris
oh um
yeah send in a video
uh the link is in the description below
or go to
watchlifeline.com and another thing that
we like doing is looking at the uh
comments
and seeing what advice you have for
everybody so go ahead and drop your
advice for the people because they're
also reading it i heard it was [ __ ]
going off in the comments on our last
episode oh really yeah yeah someone
wrote to me someone someone who had her
we we used her video and her advice and
she wrote me and was like so many people
in the [ __ ] comments were like
yeah so that's good because they read
that stuff too so you could be like if
you're watching yeah right you know
don't want to get over inundated with
that [ __ ] though there's nothing worse
than too much advice
like imagine somebody giving you
like a hundred people giving you advice
and they're all different yeah you'll be
overwhelmed i guess so yeah you're right
well don't make it sound like you
disagree with me i mean i'm right about
a lot of stuff dude oh okay uh all right
you guys thanks for watching um
chrisley.com for tickets
and uh that's it we love you thank you
you guys are good i love you all
[Music]
hello hello